here is back again it is John Barry how
are you John hello rich what's going on
are you there in Oakland right now John
I'm in San Francisco I cross the bridge
from Oakland I don't know if you've been
up in these parts John you're not
staying over across the the bay there
huh
you're staying not much to choose from
over there my man be careful you might
run into Marshawn Lynch you might have a
problem with that sort of thing I was
born in Oakland
thank you very much right that's not
please okay so you have it in your blood
yeah is your dad in my blood you have
you seen your daddy's gonna be there
tonight too I don't know if he's going
to be here tonight or the next game I
have not heard okay so let's talk about
this this series what what do you think
needs to happen for the cab's to pull
off what you what let's put it this way
fewer number of people think they can
pull off what do you got yeah
I think it's going to be closer than
that I do I think they have a great shot
I love the way they've been playing they
beat this team last year obviously they
just have to sustain their defense like
they did last year I don't think they
play great defense at any point this
season in stretches yes and gain but
their defense has to be on point against
this team this is a different animal I
mean if you really want to kind of dumb
it down it's like is Kevin Durant taking
over for Harrison Barnes and in the last
three games last year when the Warriors
were up 3-1 games five six seven
Harrison Barnes struggled big-time he
scored 15 points total in those three
games he shot five for 32 from the field
that was kind of Cleveland's design was
we're gonna leave Harrison Barnes if we
have to give up something we'll give up
Harrison Barnes being open and Harrison
Barnes struggled big-time so if you want
to do that again and that's Kevin Durant
you have a major problem on your hands
so Clayton's gonna have to devise
something a little bit different here
this year defending this Warriors team
which is even better offensively than
they were last year what do you think
that is give me your best guest is what
ty lue and everybody there is thinking
about defensively then well I think he
mix it up on staff if they're running
high pick-and-roll a lot of times you'll
see them switch with Tristan Thompson or
cap
love and love did a pretty good job last
year staying in front of stuff you know
how hurt was Steph last year there was a
lot of talk about him being banged up he
wasn't a hundred percent his last three
games after being up 3-1 were very
subpar shot under 40% in those three so
switch it up sometimes you double you
know you have to be on point later on
these rotations draymond Green
was sensational in Game seven probably
the best game he's ever played in his
life he had 32 15 and 9 so do you leave
him open you have to give up something
you know you can't take away everything
so I think you try something out and and
you adjust and you see who's got it
going
but again Cleveland held the Golden
State Warriors to 89 points in Game
seven last year and I'm not saying
that's what it's going to take but they
need that type of defensive effort
consistently to have any chance to win
this here John Barry joining me from the
Bay Area here on the Rich Eisen show as
the NBA Finals we all were anticipating
is finally happening
tonight after a lengthy break between
conference championship games and the
NBA Finals what is the plan on LeBron
they're just going to run a bunch of
people at them or do you think there'll
be one specific LeBron defender that
will be front and center I think a bunch
of guys will get a piece of them I mean
I think Durant starts there draymond
will get them Iguodala will get them you
know and it's it look their offense is
clicking their offense actually is
better they're more efficient than the
Warriors event in this postseason which
is strange but it is it LeBron James is
incredible because they'll just get
switches on him and he sees over guys he
makes passes cross-court he puts it on
the money he's shooting a career high
from the field in the playoffs right now
he's shooting a career high from three
he's 42% from three so if this guy is
making threes impossible to guard and I
don't know what you do with them I mean
you can't give him a steady diet of
things but he'll pick you apart if you
if you want to double-team him you've
got a major problem exactly
they went and got the guys they did Kyle
Korver's knocking knock down shots Kevin
Love now is playing really great
basketball shooting 47 4 3 so they have
a ton of weapons the offense is clicking
and they have the best player in the
world so I don't understand how people
don't give them a shot well what can
they pick up from Game one or half one
of the Western Conference Finals and
exploit what do you think they can pick
out of that Spurs video and and bring to
the forefront tonight John well a lot of
it self-inflicted from the Warriors when
they turn the basketball over it affects
their their offense obviously when you
don't get a shot off but it affects
their defense and they can be careless
with the ball that's really the only
thing you can say about this team over
their past three years of dominance that
can that's that's a problem for them and
the turnovers Cleveland has to force
turnovers and if they can do that they
can get themselves a lead like you saw
against San Antonio at San Antonio had
and it looked that pick-and-roll that's
what they did they had Kawhi Leonard he
stayed in the middle of the floor they
had a very difficult time double-team
him in because when you're in the middle
of the floor
that allows that player to see the whole
floor and can make all the play so
you'll see LeBron James right at the top
they'll be running a lot of
pick-and-roll with Kyrie Irving try to
get switches with Steph Curry on them
and I mean they're there's so many
different storylines and so many things
that can happen I just can't wait to see
what unfolds here tonight me too John
Barry asked get to ask him a poll
question Brockman because that does play
in a lot of storylines that you were
referring to that we haven't yet touched
in our conversation go for bran yeah
John who has more at stake in the NBA
Finals LeBron Kyrie Steph Durant
Steve Kerr yeah well I think we can make
a case for all of them uh I guess at the
end of the day I mean LeBron seems to
take the most heat he's he's kind of the
quarterback it seems like that gets all
the beef on Monday uh but I would say
Durant I mean if you know Durant joined
a team at 173 game and if they don't win
I would
say that he would probably take the most
heat what do you think Westbrook's naked
tonight John I don't know hopefully he's
on a beach somewhere I'm not going to
watch but do you think there's any part
of him that would be you know
sentimental at all or just that this
just would be too hurtful to watch and
he would just be rooting for the Cavs to
try and bring to bear what you just
mentioned with our poll question and
then I also said the same answer that
Durant can't join a 73 win team after
all this conversation with months and
months and months only to have this not
Kash getting this far yeah you know I
don't think Russell really cares um huh
honestly like he he wouldn't do it that
way and uh I don't I don't think he
really cares I mean Kevin decided to do
that I mean you have to respect this
decision he's a free agent that's
exactly what it means I'm free to go do
whatever I want to do and III don't
think Russell cares because Russell
knows that's not something he would do
so what do you think when push comes to
shove what happens here over the next
couple of weeks
well I'd say this if the Warriors win
the first two games I think it's a five
game series if they split I think it
goes the distance and I'll take the
Warriors the words that can't lose Game
seven two years in a row at home clean
fake so you think when you say the
distance you mean the full monty were
sitting there on father's day at 8 p.m.
as a country killing out and seeing
winner-take-all for one game if they
split yes I do see that I'll be flying
back from Cleveland for the third time
um
don't sound so excited about that John
but well playing Firestone and being
tired and oh really
you got that teed up literally figured I
did well we did it last week me and PJ
Carlesimo actually went out there and
and it was great day
you know I mean what would like to did
who took it down you didn't have a
please he's a seventeen so how much
candy you giving him a Gabe 78 oh really
except 17 wasn't enough really are you
so I really
seriously Johnny you scratch are you
really Scalia yes look at you must be
nice it must be nice it really I want to
go I'm gonna play barefoot actually
since it's barefoot day yeah why don't
you do that now John do you take you I
have done that if you ever done it sauce
actually I like Freddy couple stuff I
know man I I need I need every you see
me play golf John and you saw you play
25 years ago and you know how much I've
advanced in the last 25 years zero
backwards no no I haven't because I've
got I've got a Callaway sponsorship now
so you're playing the epic I am indeed
sir
I am Wow yes I heard it's hot I heard it
thought John spot-on I'm serious it
really has changed it has you know
that's great yeah thank you so next time
we're in allowed to go hey come out for
the Hall of Fame in August there'll be a
lot of fun and take me out there take do
it yeah come on then alright John we'll
chat during the finals have a great one
okay it's going to be fun guys enjoy you
bet that's John Baron so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like some of that get some more
of that on the Rich Eisen show up follow
all the information you see right here
on the Rich Eisen show